the NVIDIA GTX 1060 may just be the new
Mass consumer Workhorse card that
replaces the 970 in terms of steam
survey crushing sales why price when the
GTX 970 launched an EVGA superclocked
Edition was about
350 you might expect that evj 1070 and
everyone else's for that matter would be
about the same price nope it's about
$440 a$1 100ish increase in price
similarly a GTX 960 was about
$210 but the fancy new 1060 ranges from
250 to 300 and I expect the non- crappy
plastic ones to start at 280 or 290 is
it worth the price increase can it live
up to the hype let's find
[Music]
out Mass drop is featuring The fostex th
x00 headphones with new ebony colored
year cups check them and other drops out
at the link in the video
description so yes the GTX 1060 is here
and with it comes a fancy new Pascal GPU
named
gp106 a step down from the GP 104
sporting GTX 1080 and 1070s but still
with a lot of the goodies and
performance improvements which come with
being on the Pascal platform at all the
biggest story here however is how it
will fare against amd's offering the rx4
480 this is the first time there has
been a pascal GPU launched since the 480
was released so that makes it
interesting first though specs the 1060
features 1,280 Cuda cor a boost clock of
178 MHz 6 gigs of gddr5 V Ram which is
clocked at 8 gab bit per second and an
overall memory bandwidth of2 gbt per
second and all of that is wrapped up in
a TDP package of only 120 watts we'll
see how all of this translates to
Performance later on next let's have a
look at the allnew cooler design it's
clearly related design-wise to the
cooler found on the founders edition of
the 1070 and 1080 but has some core
differences like no back plate an Nvidia
logo that doesn't light up a physical
extension beyond the PCB to house the
fan a slightly relaxed angularity design
and no window to look into the heat sink
fans for the diecast aluminum body also
contains two coer heat pipes embedded
into the base of an aluminum heat sink
but what this card doesn't have to much
surprise is an SLI connector Now
nvidia's official statement on this more
or less is that if you want more
performance you should just buy a 1070
or 1080 instead of two 1060s cting that
they would rather Focus their support on
SLI setups for those cards instead that
being said you will still be able to use
multiple 1060s together in certain games
if those games are able to take
advantage of MDA or LDA explicit modes
in direct X12 I'd highly suggest
checking out my video on the confusing
state of SLI and multiple GPU setups raw
performance-wise it walked all over the
rx480 in every title except for Hitman
which admittedly is a pretty AMD tuned
title it won in Crisis 3 Star Wars
Battlefront and Tomb Raider all at 1440p
with very high settings enabled by 7 8
and 10 FPS respectively then in Hitman
it lost at those same settings by about
4 FPS then to layer on top of that the
story was rather similar at 4K with
medium settings but this isn't the whole
story and AMD fans before you rush down
to the comments and start screaming at
me for being what is kind of a shill at
this point we must recognize that the
1060 is 25 to 50% more expensive than
the rx480 and that's where the
conversation changes in the dollars per
frame race the rx480 wins
every single time sometimes by rather
narrow margins other than the massive
Gap in Hitman but it still wins does
that mean the 1060 is a bad card and AMD
wins no but to be clear that totally
doesn't mean AMD lost either that's not
what I'm saying the price and
performance Deltas on these cards are
significant enough that I don't even
fully agree with them being in the same
category sure if you buy the most
expensive rx480 and the cheapest 10 60
they more or less equate in price but
that's a rather odd competition I'm
happy with the 1060 and I'm very happy
with the 480 it's a good time to be a PC
Gamer that's basically all I have to say
and it's a good time to be a mobile app
developer looking for a simple payment
solution all you got to do is check out
the brain tree v.0 SDK which is one
small snippet of code and you can be all
set up in less than 10 minutes they even
have support staff ready to walk you
through the process ACC over the phone
if you need them their code supports
Android iOS and JavaScript clients and
they have sdks in seven programming
languages this makes it easy to offer
multiple Mobile payment types including
PayPal Apple pay Bitcoin venmo Android
pay cards and more all with that quick
simple single integration to learn more
and for your first
$50,000 in transactions fee free go to
brain Tre payments.com
lonus thanks for watching guys like it
if you liked it dislike if you disliked
it get subscribed if you want to see
more graphics card videos these things
are going crazy lately cuz everyone's
releasing all these different models and
stuff and I'm going to check basically
all of them out so hopefully you like
graphics card videos uh don't forget to
check out Amazon if you want to buy a
1060 check out the Forum if you want to
discuss a 1060 check the link in the
video description down below if you want
to buy a cool shirt and uh check out
this video for our 1070 superclocked
review